rozzy it's almost time to go oh okay but
before we do we have one more surprise
for two people in our audience that's
right drew okay where is malachi barnett
right here hi
how you doing sir
hi hi um you're a fireman also right
from tulsa yes ma'am
[Music]
look at that
malachi um
we heard okay you're in your dream job
you're looking for your dream girl um is
this true
yes ma'am very much so very much oh gosh
thank god
wow
you know we love love around here right
so we're always trying to hook people up
so i'm i'm just curious where is shadia
yeah shadia
oh you're you're right there oh
hello
well look who you're sitting next yes
a little birdie told us that you're you
just happen to be single right i happen
to be
happen to be thank goodness yeah
and random question what are your
thoughts on men in uniform
they're the best like i just
i want a man in uniform
well malachi meet shadia sharia a little
birdie told me that malachi was featured
in the 2021 tulsa firefighters
[Applause]
we thought that maybe
perhaps we could send you guys on a
blind date which now is not so blind
[Music]
[Applause]
we'd like to check in and see how it
goes
not at all
go ahead
okay well at a certain point maybe we'll
have some information and um if and when
you can go to the drew barrymore show
and find out some highlights possibly
but we'll see we'll just see how it goes
um enjoy and um just know we're uh
sending you uh good well wishes and cozy
vibes and basically to every single
person who came here in this audience
that's exactly what we are wishing and
giving to you hearts and goodness i
promise you we make this show for you
and we just want you to take it with you
[Music]
you